episode 2 of manifest is here ladies and
gentlemen along with new questions and
theories to explore so let's get right
into it with my questions for this
episode what are the passengers hearing
in their heads
who is the He is risen lady what special
connection do the twins have and who or
what is the shadow killer episode 2
reentry leads off with 20 of the flight
8 to 8 passengers detained after the
planes mysterious explosion the 20 start
realizing that those on board have been
hearing things and even seeing images
that called them to the plane but it
seems as though these messages aren't
limited to voices as Ben begins to hear
violin music naturally this leads him to
rad our violin player from episode 1 who
desperately needs help exonerating his
jailed son what Ben and Mikayla have
been hearing in their head seems to have
unlimited scope we can expect sounds
images signals and possibly even other
people's voices in episodes to come
nothing is off-limits
these callings give them clues guiding
them where it wants them to go the
voices also follow a similar pattern
your voice be called lead to someone in
need help that person then hears the
music and has led to rad hears it again
and discovers the jewelry shop owners
son was the one behind the robbery note
that none of the scenarios in which Ben
and Mikayla have helped people the bus
child the lock girls rad son have come
from their own investigative work but
rather are purely result of coincidence
or being in the right place at the right
time how did Mikayla know to look into
the law container how did Ben know where
the jewelry was and that Valero jr.
would be waiting there ready to be
caught red-handed even they don't know
one might say these discoveries were
miraculous this ties into the theory
that a greater power is the calling
source and religion undoubtedly plays a
heavy role in this series God works in
mysterious ways the all things work
together for good pillow again still
don't believe in miracles and
prominently He is risen he is not here
the woman here is quoting Matthew 28 6
where Jesus Christ has risen and left
his tomb she directs this to Cal a
passenger in the flight with a similar
resurrection storyline everyone was
thought long dead but is now returned
and Cal specifically was in many ways
dead or shortly going to
due to his diagnosis and now he may live
though rarely do events like these
happen just for symbolism could Cal be a
savior to come and what could that mean
for his twin olive we certainly know
that all oven Cal have more than just a
normal connection she says she knew Cal
wasn't dead she could feel him how far
will this connection go will she be able
to connect to cow's callings like Luke
and Leia through the force will she in
turn be called and then there's a big
new question mark the shadow we get our
first glimpse of it in cows drawing it's
positioned directly behind him and
closest to his mother my first instinct
was that perhaps this shadow was Grace's
secret lover but then it's seen
following around Kelly a passenger from
the flight who's decided to leaked info
to the press we begin to wonder what the
shadows and tensions are is the shadow
sinister or good or oh no yeah yeah that
thing is evil but let's rewind this
final scene kelly watches her segment on
the news
she says now that she's spoken up she
thinks the government is watching her
the natural assumption is that this
shadow is a government agent taking her
out but look at her as she's watching
focused and then she smiles this leads
me to three conclusions one the
government will take the heat for this
death but likely is not the culprit to
she either went on TV for her 15 minutes
of fame and she's enjoying the intention
or three she's up to something sinister
is she working for or with someone to
divert the public's attention is that
someone the shadow who now has no use
for her or is the shadow of being intent
on eliminating the passengers just like
the plane was eliminated perhaps them
all being called to the plane to witness
its explosion was a warning watch out
someone is out to get you either way it
seems like the 20 or 19 now on flight 8
to 8 have more to worry about than just
rebuilding lost relationships that's it
for this episode of exploring manifests
before I let you go here's a little
easter egg I noticed when Michaela goes
to make up with her friend Lourdes did
anyone notice her street number 3 5 to 8
3 plus 5 equals 8 8 to 8 coincidence or
a cheeky addition from the production
team stay tuned for more theories and
make sure to LIKE and subscribe as well
as check out my other videos until next
week